new details are emerging about Janet  Jackson's new life without her husband  but with her baby this is a story about  control a source close to the Jackson  family tells ET that Janet is back in  control of her life after her split from  assam omana  earlier this month the 50 year old is  now spending a lot of time with her  older brother Randy lives in London just  like Janet and our source says quote as  the babies of the family they have an  unbreakable bond and she trusts him more  than anyone meanwhile three-month-old  isa is as Mama's pride and joy just look  at that face things are amicable between  his mom and dad from our source says are  both committed to co-parenting our  source claims Janet couldn't stay in the  marriage because of with Psalms  controlling ways and quote the  disrespect he showed to her mother and  family  [Music]